so much to talk about first of all i
know you are touring
constantly you're on that tour bus
you're going around this great country
of ours yes i love i love touring around
doing stand-up and uh what are you
learning what are you learning about
this well you know this is a great
country much better than canada yeah no
i love canada i do everything no well
you know
we did a tour in the southeast and i'll
tell you the south uh you know people
are nicer in the south they really are
really i think they are and there's
three people yeah but there's
but they're slower and i don't mean
intelligence-wise
they just move slowly they move more
slowly right it's like hey your house is
on fire
all right
i'll get to that first
i need to drink some sweet tea
and i figured it out it's the biscuits
and gravy
it is that's it everyone in the south
moves like they've just had two helpings
they're like
this is a 9 year old i'm pretending
and you know they're eating biscuits and
gravy
for breakfast they're not coming home
drunk and crazy late at night you know
like anything they're waking up and
saying time for cement yeah
then at lunch they're eating chicken and
waffles you know the south will never
rise again because they don't have the
energy
most of their diet involves paper mache
really
they're essentially eating pinata stuff
i mean i love it like in the south they
don't even try and hide that they're
eating unhealthy like on the menu you
could be all right i'll have the bucket
of butter and the salt stick yeah and
they're like do you want to deep fry
them like of course i do [ __ ]
do it do it now i did it you uh you talk
uh because i've known you many years you
talk a lot about food you're fascinated
by food i love food you know because i'm
you know i'm fat too
but uh i don't want to brag or anything
but i have kind of an announcement
congratulations on your show by the way
but um
i you know i'm a little heavy but i'm
also i'm preparing for a big role it's a
cinnamon roll
i don't want to look like i can't finish
it
no
but no food is important it is important
i mean sharing a meal with someone
that's intimacy right that's why it was
called the last supper and not the last
meeting right right i mean jesus was
trying to get 12 guys together there had
to be food right you know jesus was like
tomorrow i'd like to get everyone
together you know one of the apostles is
like is there going to be food there
[Laughter]
yes there will be food
are we talking appetizers or like a full
entree
it will be a supper
so casual i can wear a robe right
jesus you know i'll tell you jesus he
was in amazing shape you know you see
him in those paintings he looked great
you know what i mean and it's it's even
more impressive because he looked great
and he could multiply bread whenever he
wanted
so he could be like boom
pretzel bread you know what i mean
the bible doesn't really specify what
type of bread he multiplied i imagine it
was pretzel bread right
pretzel bread boom garlic nuts yeah you
know
i wouldn't assume that at all like if i
multiply garlic knots right now you guys
would be like maybe he's god yeah
yeah
but what's even more you know who knows
maybe jesus could multiply bread but he
didn't have any control over what type
of bread it was
you know maybe he was like boom
pumpernickel hold on a second
boom melba toast that's never happened
before
[Laughter]
boom sourdough hello ladies yeah
everyone loves sourdough oh it's good
stuff